foreign
[Music]
awesome anime season on our hands now
and if you're not picking up one of the
many amazing shows then what are you
doing watching seasonal animes more fun
when you're here for the ride week after
week no offense intended to people who
prefer to binge but the experience the
community Factor the discussions it just
hits different man so if you're in and
want to pick up one of the many new
anime that made their debut this fall
season then I'm here to help you out for
today's list I'll go over what I think
are some of the best new titles we got
for this season I know you want to talk
about how awesome the new bleach looks
but let's give these new titles some
shine as well shall we probably a
surprise to Sam but we'll start the list
with Akiba made War
a show that completely fell under my
radar it surprised me even more with
what it turned out to be forget the
marketing materials forget all the
promos that they've put out this is
nothing like the cute major that has
been advertised as and that's uh
actually pretty awesome I guess I should
have some hints from the title but Akiba
made war is all sorts of chaos and
craziness but in a good way it's a very
high Tempo in your face shootout type
show something that probably reminds you
more of say um Black Lagoon in terms of
its overall feel and it grabs you and it
never lets you go filled with non-stop
over-the-top Thrills and a great Pace
that will always keep you watching and
wanting more Akiba made war is a
surprise hit this early in the season
for me
oh
[Applause]
coming up is Arc Knights Prelude to Dawn
ing
generally speaking I've made it clear
that I've warmed up to video game
adaptations yet I know they're still
kind of Hit or Miss at times but if
we're talking about shows related to a
video game or created in order to
promote another one like tact for
example there have been a lot more hits
than misses now especially compared to
when I consumed the most of this medium
which was about a decade ago arcanites
has got a lot of treats and details that
the players can definitely appreciate
but even for new Watchers unfamiliar
with the game they can find something to
love in terms of the battles and how
crisp the world looks the world and its
detailing is stunning and the story is
also interesting enough to make you want
more it's very easy to tell that this
has something to do with the mobile game
but what's not to say that long
expensive commercials are automatically
mediocre
up next is the rom-com more than a
couple less than lovers
it's time for The Season's mandatory
easy going rom-com with a dash of
contrived and fake relationships more
than a couple less than lovers turned
out to be pretty fun sure it's not the
most realistic show out there as with a
lot of school rom-coms featuring team
characters and sure it doesn't bring
anything to eye-poppingly Unique to the
table but when it comes to the things a
rom-com should do well like give us a
nice dash of Comedy pretty visuals and a
bunch of endearing characters this one
is definitely good you have your set of
characters who are so easy to root for
some great banter and interactions that
leave you smiling either out of
sweetness or laughter overall it's a
sweet romance so you could watch if it
into the genre I think it's one of the
things I can recommend this season in
spite of it possibly ending up buried
under the wave of big hits some have
compared this to love and lies so if you
like that show you should definitely
check this one out
foreign
don't go anywhere before we continue the
show as we thank today's sponsors raid
if you still don't know what raid Shadow
Legends is it's a turn-based MMORPG that
allows you to build and master over 600
Champions honing them and Fielding the
best combinations as you take on the
challenges given by the interesting Ray
dungeons campaign battles and Arena
matches I personally like the fact that
there are so many champions to choose
from there are some cool looking ones
with my top three favorite in terms of
design probably being Manaya battle
stage and Astronaut things are about to
be shaken up a little though as Ray just
released a new faction the Silvan
watches it's about time that this game
gets blessed with the presence of the
RPG staple the Elven faction featuring
ants elves Druids and the like along
with a fresh Forest pass that can let
you get some powerful gear Now's the
Time to finally jump start on playing
raid oh and that's not all if you happen
to be an Amazon Prime member Ray can
also provide some cool and exclusive
rewards just for you so if you haven't
started playing rage yet for some reason
be sure to click my link or scan my QR
code here to get started in doing so
you'll get unique bonuses worth thirty
dollars a free epic Champion called Aina
200k silver a free energy refill and XP
boost and an ancient Shard so what more
do you need and that's waiting for you
right here with an introductory package
like that there's no time like the
present to come over and play raid
we then have reincarnated as a sword
instead of being reincarnated as a human
being a slime or any living being our
protagonist here ends up becoming a
sword reincarnated as a sword takes a
pretty special premise in the large
isakai genre and rolls with it thanks to
it implementing elements of the coming
of age story with its other protagonist
Fran unlike most OP protagonist isakai
reincarnated as a sword makes the
journey feel and it's all about the
Journey of growth both of France
strength and the bond between her and
the sword protagonist shisho
reincarnated as a sword may not be
something that people talk about a lot
now honestly I don't think it will have
anything like Sao or re-zero level in
terms of leaving behind a historical
footprint but it's a great show that
even people who aren't fans of isakai
could really enjoy it's a show carried
by the strength of his characters and
while they're not the most complex ones
out there you do get the urge to follow
their journey and root for them and for
me that's way more important than having
super deep characters what good are the
latter if you can't get the audience to
constantly root for them right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
every once in a while we get this show
that hits super hard thanks to the
themes that a lot of us adolescents or
young adults can relate to and they cap
it off with characters that grab your
heart through their relatability or
simple Charisma all while they plow
through life and fight their way to the
top a notable example of it was your boy
Kong Ming and I think I found the
current season's equivalent Butchy The
Rock's main pitch in my opinion comes
from the characters a lot of us have
dealt with social anxiety at some point
to relate to her and I think she just
hits the ground running in terms of
endearing herself to us however a main
character alone can't carry a show like
this but the other characters do their
fair share of heavy lifting by being
colorful members of the cast who bring
even more life to a show that's all
about presenting a fantasized tale Meant
to hit close to home and that's not even
getting into the production side of
things Vivid colors that bring life to
the world great camera angles that
enhance moments and the constant visual
gags that never feel out of place
overall Bocce the rock is both
inspirational and entertaining fans of
chaon and hitoribochi would love this
show this could be the sleeper hit of
the season
[Music]
[Music]
next on the featured list is romantic
killer
[Music]
haven't gotten in a while I've been put
in the situation of a reverse Harem is
likely not on anzu hoshino's day-to-day
checklist but here she is and she has to
survive the Perils of her social
interaction with hot guys and yet it's
her only way of returning to her old
Carefree life of video games her cat and
snacks it's a task as daunting as ever
especially with the super unpleasant
tsugasa being at the Forefront of a
quest this show has turned out a lot
better than I first expected actually
largely due to its execution the
comedy's pretty up there and its way of
doing reverse Harem is pretty chill and
Casual more like say an oron or next
life as villains instead of those gritty
period dramas that as veteran fans have
often associated with the genre if
you're looking for what I consider to be
the surprise of the season and look no
further than romantic killer
[Music]
that's been quite a ride hasn't it I
didn't know what to expect of which from
Mercury heading into the season and I
was still surprised to see the Gundam
version of you Tina any of you guys
still remember that show there's
references everywhere that I feel is
kind of intentional it's not quite the
Gundam we're accustomed to but that's
not entirely a bad thing here with this
new star comes some New Frontiers that
the franchise can explore and The Jewels
look like they have a lot of potential
for more intricate plot threads such as
manipulation I can't wait to see where
this is gonna go overall this is a new
look at Gundam and this could be the
franchise's way of adapting to the
modern trends of the world sure it could
catch some veteran fans off guard but
I'm still excited to see this new
approach to making a Gundam anime I do
miss the wartime space operas of old
however
Eminence in Shadow is another great
title
it's great that in the same season we
have two issakai that are complete
opposites of each other in terms of
execution and appeal while reincarnated
as a sword has that whole serious us
against the world thing going for it
Eminence in Shadow takes the cheesiness
and edgy cornness of the genre and turns
it up to 11 but come on would you deny
that at least once in your life you had
a fantasy not too different from SIDS a
short found it really cool and that's
where most of the show derives its
appeal from I mean it is pretty silly
but that's what gives it its charm it
does take a while to start up with the
main plots that's something you might
want to watch out for as far as the
thing shows of this nature typically
focus on such as the animation the
beautiful character designs and the
voice acting Eminence in Shadow
impresses not blow you away type of
awesome but still in a way that tickles
all those peripheral ones that fans of
the genre have Eminence and Shadow does
have a specific Niche make no mistake
about that if you fall into it and don't
miss out on this show
[Music]
let's get to the sports hit of the
season now blue lock
[Applause]
blue locks also something that I was
very excited about coming into the
season in one of the few times in anime
we have a sports show that looks to be
quite Bleak and cynical in execution
after having my fair share of haikus and
kurokos it's quite the welcome change of
pace regardless I also tempered my
expectations a bit with regards to the
adaptation but I shouldn't have I got
all I wanted and then some battles shown
an element in an edgy Battle Royale
disguised as a sports show you can count
me in for that and that my friends is
basically what you can expect the whole
thing is also animated and drawn really
well to bring the intensity so that's a
plus Factor as these kinds of shows
thrive on the production side of things
anything to make the moments look and
sound a lot more memorable while we head
to the meat of things down the line it
also becomes a lot more cerebral and
deceptively intelligent as The Story
Goes On so it's worth staying for the
ride even if the First episodes haven't
hooked you in yet
finally we have chainsaw
of course we're not going to leave a
full 2022 video without talking about
the most hype offering the anime
industry has for us this season dark
grotesque super edgy and violent
chainsaw man has it all it also has some
stunning animation to help supplement
the Carnage you see on screen and for
people who like those things the show is
nothing but glorious but for people who
prefer other elements in anime it's also
got an intriguing story for you as well
as a whole slew of characters that keep
you guessing a lot of the characters
especially for someone I'll assume to be
a new fan have a lot underneath the
surface there's a lot to uncover from
the world to the charismatic cast that
it's presented us chainsaw man might not
be a clear-cut anime of the Season or
anything like that but it's definitely
worth the wait and the hype
[Laughter]
and that's my list I hope you picked up
a show or two to watch already if you're
interested in the top shows that I
anticipated entering the season however
you might want to check out the channel
go through my list of videos and find
that specific one and yes you might also
run into some lists that might interest
you so there is that too and thanks once
again to raid for sponsoring this video
the links in the description thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time